le festival de cannes pour finir avec
les chroniques de la croisette michel
vial nous parle notamment du dernier
film français sélectionné celui de
benoît jacquot l'école de la chair
l'histoire d'une passion amoureuse
interprétée par isabelle huppert et
vassan martinez influence records ce
soir autour des marches
une foule joyeuse avaient pris d'assaut
l'esplanade du palais pour tenter
d'apercevoir les stars du jour
ici le jury mc solaar dans un moment
tendre avec ophélie winter emmanuelle
béart andie macdowell claudia cardinale
une future star du roman policier tous
précédait l'équipe du quatrième et
dernier film français en compétition
l'école de la chair réalisé par benoît
jacquot avec isabelle huppert
de retour sur la croisette vingt ans
après son prix d'interprétation pour
violette nozière il passe à cuba vont
désormais se situer de nuit où étaient
poreuses chine
je reste pas là histoire d'une passion
entre une femme de 40 ans et un jeune
homme de 20 ans deux âges de mondains
amours éphémères qui aidera la femme à
repartir dans la vie sont tous les deux
en position d'extrême vulnérabilité et
en même temps
et
danilo d'une certaine façon on abdique
et en même temps c'est quand même elle
qui contrôle le plus la situation à tel
point que c'est quand même elle qui va
décider que cette histoire moment entre
fiction et documentaire musical entre
pêche et nostalgie le second film en
compétition de la journée velvet
goldmine de todd haynes nous ramène au
début des années 70 dans un chapitre
oubliés de l'histoire de la pop music
le glam rock
j'avais l'impression que cette période
faisait l'objet d'un oubli qui était
symptomatique de quelque chose le fait
que cette période était oublié absent tu
ma curiosité
pourquoi tout cela avait-il disparu sans
laisser de traces tandis que le puck le
grunge et le rock des sixties semblait
inépuisable donc pour toutes ces raisons
et à mesure qu on explorait ce mouvement
on s'est rendu compte qu'il témoignait
d'une sensibilité unique flamboyance
excès en tous genres provocation dans le
sexe et la mode
le film constitue un hommage aux figures
mythiques de ce mouvement
david bowie marc bolan et iggy pop entre
autres à travers le personnage kitsch et
magnifique de brian slade
dans sa tête il voulait la gloire et la
reconnaissance il voulait ce que tous
les artistes désire aller une fois
qu'ils ont fuit la rejette les stars de
mon enfance je croyais qu'elle était des
super héros alors qu'en réalité elles ne
sont que des hommes comme brian sled qui
voulait être immortel et c'est
immortalisée lui-même - sunrise
nationale enfin avant les récompenses
que lui et son jury vont avoir à
décerner dimanche martin scorsese et
recevait tout à l'heure une distinction
française des mains du ministre de la
culture témoignages d'admiration un
vieil habitué de cannes
il y 20 pour la première fois en 74 avec
mean streets